so a lot of people are concerned
confused and wondering what the hell is
going on with inflation because they're
saying inflation is going lower but just
in q1 they announced 270
000 job cuts by U.S employers up 396
above last year same time five times
more if the last time we had something
like this if you take out covid was 2009
yet people are starting to realize just
this year two or three months ago they
changed something in the Bureau of Labor
Statistics on the way they measure
inflation and people are starting to
realize why they did it to not get
people to be concerned wait till you see
some of this data in today's episode
[Music]
foreign
I want to give a quick shout out to our
sponsor fund and grow the reason why we
decided to team up with these folks is
because during times like this when we
talked to a lot of small business owners
banks are tight they're not lending to
everybody they're only giving it to the
best of the best a lot of small business
owners today need a little bit more
financing yesterday I'm talking to a guy
who are at their last hundred thousand
dollars they don't know what they're
going to be doing the bank's not giving
them anything they have the upside of
building a business but they can't find
that money a place like funding growth
can help businesses like that if that's
you this is somebody you may want to
consider they give up to 250 000 a line
of credit with zero percent interest
rate and not having to give up any of
your Equity these guys got 4 000 Plus
reviews at 4.9 Stars so it's a lot of
different people that have done business
with them as a special offer all right
team and listeners receive free access
to funding gross business funding master
class five steps to securing 250 000 in
business credit click on the link below
for this amazing opportunity you can go
to fundinggirl.com forward slash pbd so
if you get value from the video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
so they're telling us inflation today
six and a half percent give or take yeah
inflation's fine it's six and a half
it's not really as bad as you think it
is and a lot of people are confused
saying how is that even possible because
chickens up 10 and a half percent butter
is up 26 milk is up 50 egg 170 in
certain markets coffee 13 baby food 10
rice and pasta 15 bread 15 how is it
possible if all of these things are up
the way they are for you to say
inflation is only up six and a half
percent yet if you go to the official
versus The Shadow stats of how we used
to measure inflation you will notice if
you look at the blue versus the red the
red shows that inflation is only six and
a half percent but blue the top shows
we're somewhere between 13 to 14
inflation but this isn't the only thing
that you have to see what happened just
this year if you go on the BLS website
U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics they
announced something very quietly I don't
know if you heard about it or not matter
if I got loved enough you heard about it
if you did comment below it's a
beginning with the January 2023 index
scheduled for publication on February 14
2023 be Ellis plans to update the
spending weights in the calculation of
the CPI every year instead of every two
years so you may say I don't get it
what's the big deal with that let me
explain to what the big deal of this and
just kind of see the Optics if you look
at the Historical rates we're just going
to go back five years do you see that
how it goes January February March all
the way down to December and the years
so the old way of measuring inflation
let's just look at February of 2023 it
says it's six percent right so if we do
the old way of how much inflation is
higher you would measure from six
percent to February of 2021 and they
would have to say inflation is up 4.3
percent than what it was two years ago
versus the new way of measuring it they
have to go from February which is six
percent to last year which was 7.9 and
they get to say the magical words look
at our policies inflation is down 1.9
percent and you and I sit there on TV
and we hear a president say this you say
I don't understand how how can you say
something like this well it is because
of our phenomenal policies inflation is
down and we have to say all right I'm
just not feeling good maybe it's me
maybe others are not feeling it and you
start thinking like you're being maybe
gaslighted or you're the dummy you're
not the dummy you're being gaslighted
because they change the way they
measured certain data so somebody may
say who's this affecting I mean again
the person that's making money they're
probably not feeling this but the person
the low and middle income family they're
feeling this the most let me show you a
couple other charts here to look at so
here's a chart of how much food prices
increase every year since 1990. if you
look at this what year is the highest
price is increasing this year and it's
not a little bit it's astronomical
compared to any other year in the last
33 years if you go to shelter look how
much we're up in shelter is 7.9 the
average person cannot afford to have 7.9
percent of their shelter costs going up
transportation
14.6 again 33 years even if you look at
some of the things the behavior of what
you and I are doing the these things
increasing beef prices are going up most
Americans we love beef we love our
Burger we love our steak we love all of
that but beef prices are going so high
that Americans are saying we can't
afford to buy beef anymore we're
starting to eat more chicken than we ate
beef look at this chart here on what we
would consume from 1965 till today beef
has gone down because prices of beef
have gone up but look at chicken
chicken's gone up turkey is flat pork is
flat this is causing you and I to change
our consumption Behavior this is causing
people right now in the tech industry to
say how am I going to replace that
income some people are sitting around
saying how am I going to increase my
income the one thing is for sure people
are looking at what the media is telling
us that inflation is going to be fine
yet we're seeing layoffs of 396 percent
for shop cuts and they're saying how
come we're not being told the truth so
there's a difference between what the
White House tells us what mainstream
media tells us versus what you're
actually feeling trust what you're
feeling these numbers are real prices
are going up so you may be saying Pat
what's the purpose of this video is it
just to scare us what do I do about it
well there's a few different things you
can actually do about it one create
awareness talk about this talk about it
amongst your community your peers online
social Twitter tag everybody you can if
you say inflation is going lower why is
this going on did you see the BLS on the
way you're measuring why did you do it
why did we do that educate the people
around you the louder you and I we the
people are eventually they're going to
have to pay some attention to what you
have to say about it right that's number
one second thing this is not the time to
splurge it's never the time to splurge
but this is definitely not the time to
splurge and not pay attention to what
you're doing go through your credit card
see some of the old memberships that you
have that you're paying for why am I
paying for this thing 4.99 a month 9.99
a month 18 bucks a month cut a lot of
that stuff this is the season to audit
all your credit card your check card to
see exactly where you're wasting money
audit yourself before the IRS audits
your finances number three increase your
market value to the best of your ability
today skills market value whatever it
may be don't just sit there and say okay
well you know it sucks that there's
nothing I can do about it there's a lot
you can do about it by increasing market
value the way you do that is when you
bring market value to a company you're
working at they're going to have to sit
around and say this guy's very valuable
to us look what he said he made money
for us here and she made money for us
there without her we would have never
done this without him we've never done
this the more you're able to do down the
marketplace your value goes up so here's
my challenge to you at the end this is a
video you ought to watch with your
family and have a conversation started
this is like hey what do you think about
this did you know about this did you not
know about this talk about these things
together with others but if you got
value from the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel I got another
video I did May of 2021 talking about
the dangers of inflation for the future
of America I went into it very very deep
this is back in the days we would do
things on the board if you've never seen
that click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye bye
foreign
[Music]